[Fabien] Salut les Mentalos ! Aujourd'hui, je suis avec Romain Henri.
[Romain] Ben ouais.
[Fabien] Hé oui. Parce que Romain Henri, c'est qui ?
[Romain] C'est lui.
[Fabien] C'est lui.
[Fabien] Et de temps en temps, Romain Henri m'invite à manger chez lui,
le soir. C'est arrivé deux fois ? Une fois ?
[Romain] Je sais même pas. Je suis en train de calculer. Je me dis : «merde, est-ce que je l'ai déjà invité à manger? ».
[Fabien] Ben oui !
[Romain] Ben oui.
Si, une fois ! Et t'es pas venu…
[Fabien] Et je crois que cette fois-là où on avait commencé à parler de faire une
vidéo ensemble, un jour. Et aujourd'hui, je t'ai envoyé un message, cette aprèm.
T'es revenu de tournée aujourd'hui, t'étais à Aix-en-Provence.
[Romain] C'est ça.
[Fabien] Des informations essentielles, hein, que je suis en train de vous donner.
Et là, je viens de réfléchir. J'aimerais te faire focaliser sur un mot.
Donc focaliser, en fait, c'est mieux que dans l'imaginaire, parce que
comme tu choisis, t'arrives pas à focaliser, alors que si tu le prends dans un livre, c'est plus simple.
À chaque fois, si je prends un livre, on peut penser que je connais le livre par cœur,
ou ceci, ou cela… Donc on va faire un
truc hyper-clinique, étape par étape,
que ce soit le plus aléatoire possible,
que tu ne sois influencé par quoi que ce soit.
Ça, c'est ma bibliothèque. C'est la bibliothèque du suspense, tout le monde
aimerait savoir quels sont ces livres. De temps en temps, j'en prends un et j'en parle sur la chaîne, tu vois ?
C'est pas un fond vert, c'est ma vrai bibliothèque.
[Romain] Ah ouais, c'est de vrais bouquins, hein !
[Fabien] Je te propose qu'on prenne chacun un livre. Moi je te dis ce qu'il va se passer,
quand même, qu'on pense pas que j'adapte en fonction de ton choix.
Avec mon livre, on choisira un numéro de page, et avec ton livre, on choisira un mot.
Comme ça c'est toi qui choisis le
livre duquel sera issu un mot.
D'accord ?
[Romain] OK.
[Fabien] Choisis un livre, j'en choisis un aussi.
Gaston Leroux, le Fantôme de l'Opéra.
Ah, trop bien !
[Romain] Trois minutes pour comprendre la grande théorie du Big Bang.
[Fabien] Ça me donne envie de les relire, en fait, que tu le tiennes. Mais ça, c'est un truc, ça me fait souvent.
Quand quelqu'un veut m'emprunter un livre,
que j'ai pas lu, hein, depuis des années, je fais : «ah ouais ? Non… je… je comptais le relire bientôt…».
Tu sais, c'est pas vrai du tout, mais c'est comme ça, quoi.
Ça, c'est le Fantôme de l'Opéra.
[Romain] OK.
[Fabien] Qui a été écrit par Gaston Leroux, qui est né en 1868 et mort en 1927.
Ce ne sont pas des infos que je connais,
elles sont marquées ici.
On va s'en servir, comme c'est un bon pavé, pour choisir un numéro de page.
Par contre, il m'a pas l'air d'avoir énormément de pages, quand même, dans celui-là. Ouais.
Tu vas choisir un numéro de page, pour ça c'est simple, tu feuillettes.
Tu vois ? Tu t'arrêtes à une page, tu vois ?
Et tu lis le numéro de la page. Voilà, page 443, hop !
Comme par contre, y'a pas… y'a moins de 200 pages,
feuillettes dans, plutôt… plutôt dans le début.
Tu ouvres, et tu refermes.
[Romain] OK, ça marche.
[Fabien] Tu retiens le numéro de page dans ta tête, tu me le dis pas.
[Romain] Ça marche.
[Fabien] Donc t'ouvres comme ça pile-poil à une page où tu veux.
Tu ouvres à une page.
T'as lu ? T'as refermé ?
[Romain] Ouais.
[Fabien] C'est bon, OK, super.
Si c'est une page comme ça, par contre, tu choisis un mot ici, tu vois.
Parce que des fois, y'a des pages comme ça.
Et puis sinon tu prends le titre.
[Romain] Ouais.
[Fabien] On fait ça ?
[Romain] Ça marche.
[Fabien] Qu'est-ce t'en penses ? Oui ? OK.
Alors ! Alors attends, je récapitule. Je récapitule, parce que là c'est en train de partir en n'importe comment.
Donc, t'as choisi un livre pour focaliser sur un mot. J'ai choisi un livre sur lequel
t'allais prendre un numéro de page au hasard. T'as pris un numéro de page au hasard,
y'a que toi qui le connaît.
Du coup tu vas ouvrir,
le livre que toi t'as pris, à cette page-là au hasard, comme ça on est sûr que
y'a pas de complicité ; ca peut être, tout ça, que aléatoire, tu vois ?
C'est clinique. Je regarde pas.
Tu lis le titre dans ta tête si c'est une page à titre. Si c'est une page à…
une double page, lis la légende de la photo, j'en sais rien…
C'est bon ?
[Romain] Ouais.
[Fabien] Tu refermes.
[Romain] OK.
[Fabien] T'as refermé ?
[Romain] Ouais.
[Fabien] OK, cool ! Je prends un bloc-note, et un crayon.
[Romain] Ça marche.
[Fabien] Est-ce que le premier mot du titre est un article, un mot court ?
[Romain] Non.
[Fabien] Non ? C'est un vrai mot, euh…
[Romain] Un vrai mot.
[Fabien] Un vrai mot. D'accord, OK.
C'est pas «le», « la », « les », « un », « une », « des » ?
[Romain] Non.
[Fabien] OK, ça marche.
C'est possible, ça ? Bon, je sais pas.
Est-ce que le premier mot que t'as en tête est un long mot ?
[Romain] Ouais.
[Fabien] OK.
Je vais essayer de trouver la première lettre.
[Romain] OK.
[Fabien] Pour ça, c'est simple, je te regarde.
Vous pouvez le regarder en même temps.
Alors c'est très dur pour moi sur un
comédien, parce que ça a l'habitude de
truquer un peu ses émotions. En vrai, c'est vrai ?
[Romain] Non, mais je vais essayer d'être le plus…
[Fabien] Pense à la première lettre.
Ça peut être une consonne ou une voyelle. OK, à «consonne», t'as vraiment
bougé la tête. C'est une consonne, c'est correct ?
[Romain] Hmm.
[Fabien] OK.
Ça peut être, A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H, I, J, K…
Je l'ai passé, c'est correct ?
[Romain] Ouais.
[Fabien] OK.
«F» ?
[Romain] Ouais.
[Fabien] OK.
[Romain] Il m'énerve déjà. (Rire)
On sait que… on sait que c'est un livre qui parle du cosmos, et cætera, donc
le titre forcément doit en parler.
[Romain] Ouais.
[Fabien] OK.
Est-ce que t'es capable de te représenter par image ce que veut dire le titre ?
Apparemment non. T'as pas…
OK, c'est pas genre… une machine à laver bleue, quoi, tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
[Romain] Ouais, non. C'est pas évident à identifier… visuellement.
[Fabien] Dommage. Je cherche comment je vais trouver en prenant des techniques un peu inhabituelles.
OK. Je sais. Tu vas prendre mon poignet, d'accord ?
Et dans ta tête, sans me faire bouger le
poignet, tu vas imaginer que tu écris
le titre en majuscule.
D'accord ? Par exemple, après le «F», tu ferrais quelque chose d'autre, tu vois ?
J'ai une résistance ici. Tu partirais d'ici, c'est ça ?
[Romain] Ouais.
[Fabien] OK.
D'accord, c'est très, très long, c'est correct ?
[Romain] Ouais.
[Fabien] Très, très long, OK.
[Romain] J'ai résisté parce qu'au début je pensais que t'allais… qu'on faisait que la lettre qui suivait,
pas le mot complet.
[Fabien] Après le mot complet, y'a d'autres mots ?
[Roman] Euh… oui. Que j'ai pas forcément…
[Fabien] Retenu. OK.
[Romain] Si, enfin je les ai, mais c'est le titre… complet, quoi.
[Fabien] Si je dis que la deuxième lettre c'est un «A»,
est-ce que j'ai bon ?
[Romain] Ouais.
[Fabien] Oui. OK.
Alors, deux solutions. Soit j'essaye de trouver le mot en entier,
soit j'essaye de retrouver ta page dans le livre. Tu préfères quoi ?
[Romain] Non, le mot.
[Fabien] Ah, putain. En fait, ce serait plus simple pour moi, parce que comme j'ai déjà
deux lettres, j'ai plus qu'à faire par…
[Romain] Ah oui, d'accord !
[Fabien] OK.
Est-ce que… Je vais dire des mots,
et toi, tu vas juste te concentrer. Quand ça
rime,
dans ta tête, tu dis : «ça rime».
D'accord ? Par exemple, je dis «chien», si ton mot finit en «-ien», dans ta tête
tu dis : «ça rime».
Quand ça rime pas, tu dis rien, OK ?
Donc… Chien.
Chat.
Mouton.
Factice.
Électrique.
Ça a bougé un peu sur «électrique». OK.
Fantasmagorique.
Vous voyez ses lèvres ? Faites un zoom, mettez au ralenti, voyez les lèvres faire…
[Romain] (Rire) Parce que… c'est le mec qui saurait pas mentir.
Ça me fait rire.
[Fabien] J'ai quelque chose. Je vais mettre ça comme ça.
Est-ce que tu peux me dire s'il-te-plaît quel mot tu avais en tête ?
[Romain] «Fantastique».
[Fabien] «Fantastique» !
[Romain] Ouais, c'est ça, ouais.
[Fabien] Oui !
Merci, mec !
Fantastique, fantastique…
Est-ce que tu te souviens du titre en entier ou pas ?
[Romain] Euh… je crois, ouais.
[Fabien] Fantastique… qu'est-ce qu'ils pourraient mettre? Fantastique…
T'es dans le milieu du livre, donc on a déjà…
aborder toutes les bases.
Je sais pas, «le fantastique chemin du Big Bang»,
ou «fantastique histoire du Big Bang» ?
[Romain] On est pas loin, parce que c'est pas
facile à…
à imaginer en fait.
Donc le Big Bang, c'était un… ?
Qu'est-ce que…
[Fabien] «Fantastique naissance du Big Bang» ?
[Romain] Non.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a encore comme traces du Big Bang de nos jours ?
[Fabien] Bah, le son.
[Romain] Ouais. Donc… et c'est un… ?
[Fabien] «Fantastique écho du Big Bang» ?
[Romain] Bien joué !
[Fabien] Bon là, c'était un peu laborieux par contre, pour le coup.
[Romain] Ouais, mais c'est parce que c'est hyper-difficile à…
[Fabien] Est-ce que ça te plaît ?
Est-ce que ça t'a plu ?
[Romain] Ouais, carrément.
[Fabien] «Ouais, bon je peux y aller maintenant ?»
[Romain] (Rire) Non mais c'est surtout le «F», je me dis
comment t'as trouvé le « F » ?
[Fabien] Je l'ai trouvé vite. Mais tu pourras le revoir dans la vidéo. Demain, à 17 heures.
Elle sort demain.
J'attends même pas, tu vois, c'est comme ça.
Et là on s'en rend moins compte, mais Romain Henri,
il est hyper-speed, et il a des trucs hyper-drôles. Là, forcément, c'est moi qui te
demande de te concentrer donc je te laisse pas te lâcher,
mais si vous voulez voir Romain Henri en
vidéo,
il fait des vidéos toutes les semaines.
C'est tous les dimanches.
À 16 heures ?
[Romain] 17.
[Fabien] 17 heures. À la base, il les met sur Facebook, mais
il les met aussi sur YouTube. Il comprend
pas que c'est YouTube qui est le plus important.
Allez voir ses vidéos.
Regardez si ça vous plaît. Si ça vous
plaît, abonnez-vous, évidemment.
Mais, regardez au moins. Je vous mets le lien dans la description.
T'as combien de vidéos ?
[Romain] Euh… 22.
[Fabien] 22 !
[Romain] 22 ! J'ai bientôt plus de vidéos que d'abonnés !
Y'a que ma famille, c'est gênant.
[Fabien] Allez voir ce qu'il fait, le concept c'est
«je dis ça, je dis rien».
Qui finit toujours par : «je dis ça, je dis
rien…»
[Romain] «… bah ferme ta gueule».
[Fabien] « … bah alors ferme ta gueule ».
On sait pas d'où lui vient cette joie de vivre, mon gars, mais alors…
Quatre heures de train pour revenir d'Aix, on était fabuleux.
[Romain] Ouais, mais il m'a donné plein de cafés, hein.
[Fabien] C'est vrai. Regarde.
Y'en a encore là. Je te l'ai mis dans une tasse à cœur.
Pour te dire que je t'aime.
Tu vois, je te mets plein de pouces en l'air.
Comme ça. De pouces en l'air.
[Romain] Je sens des messages subliminaux.
[Fabien] Pas du tout !
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère que ça vous aura plu. Merci à toi
Romain d'être venu juste après ta
tournée, d'être passé à la maison, ça c'est cool aussi.
Merci beaucoup, n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner, si c'est pas déjà fait, avant
de partir parce que le Mental Vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an, du premier janvier au
trente-et-un décembre, donc rendez-vous demain,
à 17 heures. Ciao.
(Générique de fin)